[Música]
desde pequeño siempre fue muy curioso yo
no sé como muchos de ustedes es algo
natural del ser humano preguntarse el
porqué y el cómo de las cosas estas
cosas ayudaron en mí un deseo por sobre
parece saber sobre la vida por la
biología el estudio de la vida y ahí va
yo levantándome cada mañana levantándome
cuidadosamente con el pie derecho
para poder así aprender algo de lo que
ya está escrito sobre la vida y iba
armando mi cerebro con una armadura de
información super cool y un día me
encontré con la magia
esta tarde vamos a recrear ese momento
porque lo recuerdo perfectamente fue un
día un verano de 1984 donde ustedes le
van a hacer el favor de ser yo y yo voy
a hacer un señor con sombrero barba
sonrisa amable y sensual y llego
y se puso en la mesa en la que estaba
justo en frente
me empezó a decir que se le hace muy
curioso como pensábamos las personas
siempre de manera lineal tomó dos cartas
les hizo un poco de énfasis y las dejó
en una esquina de la mesa y luego me
dijo por ejemplo la numeración
la numeración es algo que todos
conocemos
sabemos recuerden que ustedes son yo
que después del 1 que además dice uno
atrás y aparte también el uno adelante
cuál sigue
el 2 y el 2
después el 2
siguen
el 36 tienen razón el 93
entonces es 1234 y por último el
el qué
lo mismo dije yo ese día
entonces le bastó para tomar una carta
de las que tenía en la esquina una que
significa reversa para que esta mano que
nunca se había movido se volviera aquí
el 1 y justo debajo del 1 se venía
también el 2 y justo debajo de dos
tenientes y justo después de 3 694 y
justo hasta el último la primera carta
que puso fueren 5
yo quedé impresionado y aplaudí también
esa vez
y me dijo espero que estén si se pudiera
ser diferente entonces tomó la otra
carta
era un comodín y me dijo bueno ahora
tenemos que las cartas son rojas pero
también tenemos azul verde y amarillo
por ejemplo chico guapo de sudadera café
dime un color en que quieras de éstos
azul lo mismo dije yo ese día me
sorprende la exactitud de este momento
entonces estas cartas que eran rojas le
bastó pasar su mano
para pudiendo escoger cualquier los
colores se vinieron la carta azul el
número 5 y nosotros se vinieron la carta
azul sino que debajo del 5 el 4 también
fue el azul debajo del 4 es 3 también
fuera azul dejó el 3 2
el horno también fuera azul
también seguirla viendo ese día
y luego me dijo qué tal si no podríamos
hacer un poquito distinto qué tal si nos
cansamos de este juego pues nada más
tendríamos que decir uno
pues uno no que nada más nos quedaron a
cargo o si no nos hubiera gustado juego
de principio pues tomar la carta y que
la carta se fuera y quedaremos
totalmente vacío
este hombre me comentó así debería ser
el pensamiento deberíamos poder
invertirlo deberíamos poder cambiarlo de
color deberíamos poder aparecer o
desaparecer lo a nuestra voluntad
yo me quedé anonadado viendo la mesa
unos segundos y cuando levanté la mirada
este señor ya no está
ya ustedes vuelven a hacer ustedes yo
vuelvo a ser yo
después de la gran sorpresa que tuve
después de ese momento de impacto
sucede dado a mí algo muy extraño no no
lo había sentido y fue que deseaba con
todo mi corazón saber cómo demonios
había hecho es como algunos de ustedes
esta tarde
y me di cuenta de algo más que empezaba
a cuestionar
las cosas que había aprendido desde la
primaria tantas planas que me pusieron a
hacer con el orden de los números 1 2 3
4 5
y así cientos de veces me empezar a
cuestionar cosas sobre la materia me
empezaba a cuestionar sobre las cosas
que podía o no hacer y me di cuenta de
algo más de lo más importante
que no saber algo o cuestionarme en las
cosas que sabía me incomodaba y me di
cuenta porque en ese momento llegaron
flashback sami de la primaria cuando yo
tenía un hit y entraba al pizarrón y
estaba inseguro de saber si la respuesta
que quiere escribir estaba bien o estaba
mal me sentía inseguro cuando alguien
preguntaba algo y así supiera la
respuesta era como
incluso había momentos que ya no eran
tan de niño en los que me hacían
dramaticemos un poco que me preguntaban
dos más dos y mi cerebro lóbulo 4 pero
por si acaso agarrara mis dedos 2 + 2 4
y por si acaso sacaba mi celular sonaba
2 + 2 y ya veía que era 4 y ya les podía
dar una respuesta entonces me di cuenta
que toda esta inseguridad que sentía me
hacía tener una necesidad humana de
conocer muchísimas cosas de hiper
racionalizarlas de buscar patrones e
imponer los para que yo me sintiera
seguro y me di cuenta que muchas de las
cosas que aprendí a las aprendía de
manera lineal que no me cuestionaba
otras cosas y me di cuenta que para
seguir aprendiendo
necesitaba cuestionar lo que ya sabía y
ver si lo podía hacer de maneras
diferentes e inventar nuevas reglas e
inventar nuevas formas de jugar incluso
si sólo es un juego como el 1 pero esta
manera de pensar me ayuda a que ya no
solo juegue con cuatro personas que
pueda contar una historia y pueda jugar
con cientos de ustedes
y me di cuenta que tal vez esta armadura
que él estaba poniendo a mi cerebro de
información en vez de volverlo más
fuerte y en vez de hacerlo del círculo
tal vez lo estaban sofocando y que este
casco que le estaba poniendo tal vez no
me dejaba ver tantas cosas que no sabía
y que podía disfrutar
desde ese momento agarré mi cama la
pegué del lado derecho a la pared y me
empecé a levantar con el pie izquierdo a
veces de levantado con el derecho pero
clases cruzado por a veces me levantaba
con los dos para levantarme de manera
diferente y así tratar de ver las cosas
diferentes como se habían hecho hasta
ahora
seguí estudiando biología empecé a
estudiar la magia y me encantó porque
veía la magia con un método científico
observaba experimentar ahí todo y la
ciencia la empecé a ver de un modo
mágico y me di cuenta que empecé a
disfrutar de no saber y que en ambas
ramas había muchísimas cosas que se
podían explorar en ambas ramas me di
cuenta que todos somos ignorantes pero
no todos ignoramos algunas cosas
me dio cuenta que faltan planetas por
explorar me di cuenta que hace falta
saber muchísimo hacia el centro de la
tierra y muchísima información sobre
cómo sentimos y cómo pensamos y si ya sé
que en la presentación dice ignoramos
cometió un error no pasa nada no lo sé y
no vamos a ver ayuda muchísimas cosas no
saber me ayuda a pensar bueno que te sin
estos planetas que no conozco existirá
la vida que estás inventó algo para
saber si hay vida en otros dados que
animales submarinos
va a haber muchísimas millas abajo de
los océanos incluso podríamos inventar
cosas para saber cómo sentimos o cómo
pensamos
en palabras del nuestro kevin johansen
dice hay cosas que sé que estoy seguro
que sé y hay cosas que no sé hay cosas
que no sé que sé y hay cosas que no sé
que no sé no entiendo nada pero me
encanta y yo agradecido pues sólo quiero
bailar
esta unión de la biología y la magia me
hizo llevar las cosas sobre todo el
cerebro y preguntarme cómo es que nos
podemos sorprender no cómo es que este
cerebro tan maravilloso que siempre
hemos salvado también tiene ciertas
contradicciones y me encontré con este
libro de susan stephen que se llama los
engaños de la mente donde tratan
muchísimos temas al respecto sobre cómo
el cerebro se puede contradecir puede
ser beneficioso o puede causar de ahí
sus contradicciones aquí voy a hacer un
paréntesis súper importante y es que no
me gusta la traducción de este libro los
engaños de la mente si es un engaño no
es máximo incluso muchos magos le dicen
a la magia el arte del engaño pero un
engaño te hace sentir mal un engaño es
como cuando tu pareja te dice me voy de
vacaciones del puerto rico con mi amiga
hogwarts
no era su amiga y si es una canción de
romero santo sido animal
la ma que yo la veo más como una fiesta
sorpresa una fiesta sorpresa en la que
ciertas personas ocultamos un pequeño
porcentaje de la información para cuando
tú abras la puerta te sorprendas yo no
me sé mago para engañar a la gente
me hice mago para inspirar a asombro ya
que el asombro cambia al mundo entonces
en este libro que no voy a mencionar
subtítulo porque me enoja susan y
stephen mencionan que la magia es como
en jiu jitsu entonces les voy a contar
una pequeña historia se encontraba un
antiguo maestro oriental viendo una
tormenta y observaba dos cosas uno como
los sauces que tenían ramas fuertes y
frondosas cuando los chocaba el viento
se empezaban a romper y como los cerezos
que tenían flores y ramas muy delicadas
nada más sepan de abba y volvían a su
normalidad
y lo que determinó este maestro fue que
en una pelea luchando contra la gente
con armadura su gente mucho más fuerte
podías ocupar su fuerza para derribarlos
y así vencerlos
entonces para mí eso es la magia no
podrán ver este buen meme que dice que
está la magia apretando el
internacionalismo y de eso se trata la
magia de no comprender algo y poder
disfrutarlo de adentrarte a lo
desconocido y sorprenderte
sí qué sorpresa en muchos lados sé qué
sorpresa en el arte sé qué sorpresa en
los paisajes sé qué sorpresa en las
personas sé qué sorpresa cuando volteas
a ver a alguien le sonríe y te vuelve a
sonreír dobet pero la magia me gusta
porque desafía hasta cierto punto un
límite de razón cosas que ya conocíamos
las tomamos y las vemos de otra manera
con esto les quiero decir algo más yo
como mago no quiero que piensen que
puedo agarrar un sombrero y que pueda
parecer un conejo de la nada mucho menos
quiero que piensen que puedo adivinar la
lotería o que pueda parecer dinero y
mucho mucho menos quiero que piensen que
puedo desaparecer a su suegra ya basta
por favor esto para mí ya no sé qué
decirles lo que yo quiero que piensen es
que tal si con las cosas que hay en el
aire existe una manera para tomarlas
condensarlas y volverla a su meta que
está existe metal lo pudiéramos tomar lo
pudieron ser más liviano de tal manera
que bote hasta arriba qué tal si
pudiéramos formar ese metal
y los pudiéramos después
obviamente lo que les cause a ustedes es
intriga y ustedes van a pensar en que
pueden hacer las cosas pero tal vez de
un modo diferente
a este modo de pensar nosotros le
llamamos secreto hay dos secretos muy
importantes para mí el primer secreto es
la práctica constante práctica práctica
práctica lo de la moneda que evitar
hacia arriba así medio feo con massa le
meta todo tres meses tres meses y que se
me cayera tantas veces que en algún
momento mi mamá me dijera
si se te cae una vez más tomas las
maneras y te vas de la casa entonces
ahora estoy buscando donde rentas
mana cierto muchas gracias en familia y
a todos mis amigos que siempre me han
apoyado pero entonces es la práctica
constante y en algunas ocasiones son
aparatos artilugios que tienen un
mecanismo tan sorprendente que igual si
los ven ustedes van situó como diablos
alguien se le puede ocurrir esto tanto
tiempo debes tener libre para que se te
ocurra es bueno
les cuento este secreto por dos cosas
porque no creo que solo los que nos
llamen los magos o no solo a los que nos
llaman magos podamos ser magos creo que
cualquier científico deportista
empresario que tú veas y digas cómo lo
hizo
y esa persona es un mago una persona que
reviva tu curiosidad y que te hace
disfrutar el que no sepas algo
describí en esta frase que es de un
malgasto que se llama paul hardy que se
puede tomar cualquier actividad arte
disciplina o habilidad hacerla tuya
llevarla extremos salvajes el abrazo
introducido al reino de la máxima
con esto los extremos salvajes quiero
darles una advertencia
a veces practicar tanto está mal yo por
ejemplo visualizo siempre incluso si no
traigo mis cartas entonces luego voy en
el camión
voy como taiana cambió de color y había
un viejo que contaba una historia
ella como él entiendo no porque no saben
lo que yo estoy pensando no saben no
está mal
el segundo secreto es mucho más simple
es que solo se ve bien con el corazón lo
esencial es invisible para los ojos les
cuento esto porque por qué
descartes estaba mal al pensar que somos
mente tratando de entender un cuerpo
biológicamente somos primeros seres
emocionales antes que ser racionales y
somos un conjunto de ambas entonces no
somos máquinas pensantes que tratamos de
entender las cosas que tratamos de
entender los sentimientos son más como
sentimientos que están tratando de
entender el mundo que tratan de entender
todo a través de pensamientos
mecanizados por eso a veces nos cuesta
un poco de trabajo ya que tenemos estas
dos cosas que tenemos un modo de
expresarnos que tenemos la práctica
constante podemos llegar a lo que le
llamamos el pensamiento mágico los magos
un pensamiento mágico resumido es que
por ejemplo alguien venga y me diga oye
amigo quiero averiguar cómo la sorpresa
ayuda a desarrollar el factor
neurotrófico del cerebro y hoy día como
huevo huevo oye tranquilo pero no está
nada escrito de esto ni siquiera sabemos
si existe me encanta la idea que es que
empecemos soy yo
pero
por último quiero terminar esta frase
que es de julio verne que dice que el
gran libro se puede escribir con lo que
se sabe pero el libro muchísimo más
grande se puede escribir con lo que no
se sabe
[Aplausos]